hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and as you know if you've been
listening to this podcast I'd like to
mention books that I have written or I'm
in the process of writing my most recent
book that has actually appeared as of
course called the big picture and it was
an attempt to put together the laws of
the physical world with the human side
of things and this is an element of a
genre right there's a kind of book where
you try to synthesize some gigantic
picture of things and it's you know
their successes and less successful
books in this genre our guest today is
Nicholas Christakis who is the author of
one of the most recent attempts in this
genre it is called blue print now
Nicholas unlike me is not a physicist
he's a well it's hard to say what he is
I want I almost said he's a social
scientist but one of the things he
brings to the table as an author of an
incredibly sprawling book like this is
that he seems to be a professor of
everything he was originally a medical
doctor and now I have to read this from
the back of his book he is at Yale
University the Sterling professor of
social Natural Science and particularly
he's appointed in the department's of
sociology medicine ecology evolutionary
biology statistics and data science and
biomedical engineering as well as being
the co-director of the Yale Institute
for Network science so he's a
sociologist a medical doctor he studies
ecology and networks applied math a
whole bunch of things
so in blueprint he's trying to put this
all together right he's trying to write
a book about humanity and what makes us
special not just culturally but how that
relates to our biology our genetics how
we came to be different than other
animals in different ways and he
identifies what he calls the social
sweet the list of the sweet su ite so
it's a suite of characteristics that
make us human and some of them are good
things like the capacity for love or
cooperation some of them might not sound
so good like the existence of in-group
bias we like people like ourselves we
don't like people not like ourselves the
preference for hierarchies and so forth
but the overall message that he comes
away with is an optimistic one that's
what makes this book special
in a sense he's not simply saying how
terrible human beings are he's saying
that there is good reason to be
optimistic about what we can become
and you know it's not a hundred percent
right it's not at all determined he has
examples in the book for example of
societies that were created after
shipwrecks so little semi controlled
experiments with small numbers of people
some of these experiments went terribly
wrong but some of them turned out really
really well so Nicholas wants to make
the case that what makes us human is
part of what makes us good and we do
have reason to be optimistic about the
future you know of course as long as we
don't destroy the planet or anything
like that so let's see how that's going
to happen and let's go
[Music]
Nicholas Christakis welcome to the
mindscape podcast thank you so much for
having me Sean so I do you know I want
to dive right into the the meaty
substance you've written 500 page book
very very good I've never quite reached
the 500 page mark in any of my books
I've come 400 and some a couple of times
but you also you know I'm equally
intrigued by the about the author
section at the end of your book because
you have an MD a PhD you've been a
hospice doctor and you're talked about
as a sociologist tell us you know how
you think about yourself and how you got
to be this oh goodness I mean I think to
me one of the most interesting
observations about Sciences or more
generally about scholarly inquiry is
that innovation and novelty often come
at the intersection disciplines and
there's this idea is often realized in
many ways I I talked to my graduate
students I say you know yes death but
also some breadth early on you know go
to nearby you know a meetings and
conferences and departments and see what
they're doing and you never know when
you get a good idea unexpectedly you
know you might be building a kind of a
laser a laser device and go to a taught
by a biologist about how natural
selection has solved a similar problem
you know millions of years ago in the
design of an insect I for instance for
the same principle comes up when you
think about civilizations and there's
this wonderful lecture about you know
what ideas have sex you know like
innovations come at at the intersection
of trade routes right where people mix
and ideas mix and and I think I think
the same thing happens in in Discovery
it's not just a pedagogic tool it's not
just a argument about the emergence of
novelty and ideas at the sort of at a
civilizational level I think it happens
at the level of a work of us practicing
scientists where if you cultivate some
breath in yourself you're able to
discover new things so so in my own
career I tried to do that I've tried to
be as broadly educated as I can
be and I have rather enjoys and so but
but alright let's let me play the part
of the devil's advocate here yes do you
you you've just cast this
interdisciplinary nature of your work as
a rational instrumental good thing to do
so is it mostly that or is it mostly
that you just like it it's both I mean I
derive a lot of section I mean the thing
is you know I forced like most people
you know I think again it's I just I
want to emphasize that I think it's
important to have expertise ok yeah I'm
not advocating for being a dilettante
and I think it's important to to have
skills to have depth but I also think
it's important to keep your head up and
look around and people different
disciplines and different people do that
at different phases of their career and
in my case I may heavy investments in my
20s in both the natural and the social
sciences and you know the biological and
the social sciences and you know I know
over the course of my career I tried
very hard to to keep those parts alive
and to look for opportunities for
discovery at the intersection of those
fields so that's why for instance a lot
of the work I've been doing has been on
the evolutionary biology of friendship
for example you know right how and why
we evolved to have friends that's a
question at the overlap of those fields
so and yeah I've been sort of deliberate
yeah and so so you've come out with this
wonderful new book called blue is it
blueprint or the blueprint sorry I
forgot from blueprint blueprint no as I
said yeah 500 pages it has the feeling
of you know a summing up of many years
we're both too young to have you know
anything that is specifically the
culmination of our career quite yet but
it does have this synthetic vibe to it
so of course what I'm going to ask you
to do is to summarize it in 30 seconds
or less for our readers what is the
point of the book what's the elevator
pitch well I think I think for too long
in my view the the social sciences and
the and the biological sciences and sort
of the person on the street have been
obsessed with the role of our evolution
and shaping our propensity for bad
things our propensity for violence and
tribalism and selfishness and men
city but equally natural selection has
shaped us for good has shaped is
equipped us with capacities for love and
friendship and cooperation teaching and
I would argue that these these qualities
these good qualities over the sweep of
our evolution must necessarily have
outweighed away the bad qualities you
know if if if every time I came near you
you killed me or you were leaving me you
mean to me or you or you filled me with
lies you know give you fake news or
information that was false about the
world then there'd be no utility of my
being near you and I would evolve to be
solitary animals but we're not we're
social animals so the benefits of a
connected life must necessarily have
outweighed the costs and the subsidiary
ideas to that there a number of surf you
know motifs one of those is that to the
extent of these core features are good
and to the extent that they have been
shaped by natural selection they give us
a kind of a lever or a kind of insight
into our common humanity the fact that
humans around the world share these
properties we all do because we're all
the same species they are seen again and
again in the kind of core fundamental
Universal cultural set of cultural
universals which are a universal and be
good so it gives us a kind of kind of
opportunity to empathize with each other
and and kind of address in some ways
some of the forces that might otherwise
do by us these are modern political
forces but that's not my main agenda um
so those are some of the themes of the
role of natural selection in shaping not
just the structure and function of our
bodies not just a structure and function
of our minds but the structure and
function of our societies how how have
we been shaped across our evolution to
manifest particular forms of social
order
why are those forms of social order
Universal why are those forms of social
order good and and what this is telling
how how do they become to be that way so
that's those are some of the big ideas
in the book yeah I mean okay that was
more than 30 seconds but that's okay
there's a lot of panic in that's
perfectly fine John I know but you got
to work on your you know I live
you gotta work on your Finch yes sir
so it's it's Guns Germs and Steel meets
better angels of our nature
perfect there you go now I'm thinking
about studio deals okay good then it's a
it's a fundamentally optimistic book
right I mean that's and it was this was
it just because that's how the facts led
you or do you think about it as coming
into being within a milieu of other
discussions going on and you want to
push back against certain trends both
you know I think that is where the facts
led me and I um I mean there's no doubt
that we've also been shaped for all
kinds of awfulness and every century
every millennium every epoch is replete
with horse you know warfare and and
pogroms and inquisitions and and war you
know to call it Holocaust and nuclear
weapons and every every other evil you
can imagine you know incompetent
leadership and so so that's true and me
and many of those propensity is of
course are also part of our nature so
part of it was my desire to focus on the
good side but it's insanity directed my
gaze there but part of it as well was
the fact that I think there's so much
evidence about this that that hasn't
been given the do it deserves and that
also has it been seen to counterbalance
those other qualities enough so yeah
that's where I was coming from no I
think it makes perfect sense and and you
just so if anyone you know only gets to
listen to the first ten minutes of
podcast I want them to get the the
take-home message here that I think the
the central point of the book is what
you call the social sweet is that a fair
thing to say so this is a list of eight
things that are both well number one you
say they're common to human beings in
human societies and number two we're
gonna attribute that commonality to
evolution to our genes
yeah they're not just accidents of
history right correct and also very
pertinent Lee there are specifically
social qualities so for example I'm not
discussing in this book those attributes
of our human nature
we might manifest as isolated
individuals for example the way natural
selection is shaped you to be
risk-averse or religious for instance
you could do those on your own right you
could go through the world on your own
I'm interested in those things that we
necessarily must Express between
ourselves these things include things
like love and friendship social networks
cooperation in-group bias the preference
of us versus them kind of mild hierarchy
and the practice of teaching and
learning and the eighth element is this
capacity for individual identity this
this ability that we have to to express
our individuality which very
paradoxically also lies at the core of
our sociality that's very good you got
them all you didn't get them in the
right order that you put them in the
book but I remembered all eight of them
and summarized them very very nicely so
these are characteristics that human
beings have that play a role in our
social world as you say and for the most
part they sound good love and friendship
and cooperation there's a couple in
there that don't so we'll get to those
is there a simple way of saying how you
came upon this list of eight like you
know it was it a whole bunch of things
and narrowed it down or did you keep
adding as you studied more things well I
suppose it could be like the standard
model you know you you find you know you
first you find neutrons oh we should say
that you have we have physicists in your
family yes we can use the physics
analogies all we want to spend yes yeah
you know so we first define feel like
the electrons and the protons and the
neutrons and then we say wait a minute
you know they are composed of you know
the quarks and subsidiary particles and
then eventually we even get to
antimatter you know so you got positrons
and you I mean it's just you know so we
can keep going down and down and I think
I suppose I would put this at the level
of you know the first cut so neutrons
protons and electrons these are a
complete set of things that I think you
can be used to define a social order as
a first-order approximation now there
are constituent elements in these things
which I allude to but I don't go down
and you might even are
more fundamental for example I talk
about empathy but I don't include
empathy as its own independent quality
so and I talk about I talk about
religion for instance but I don't
include religious which we clearly have
natural selection has shaped our
religious capabilities for example but I
don't include that because that's
something you can express on your own
you know you could just or night so
again I narrow my gaze to look at these
types of things
speaking of empathy I did have your Yale
colleague Paul bloom on the podcast anti
empathy and I bravely took on the pro
empathy side do you do you have a dog in
that particular fight well I mean I
think you know Paulo sure he's wonderful
and yeah
he's yes you know this book is very
provocatively titled which I an
ingenious and title you know he's not
he's he doesn't think everything is bad
you know I know you know so exact but
it's very clever because he does make an
argument you know the downside then
defeat why we as you point out so so how
did you do when your are clearly won no
he admitted that I was right about
everything no yeah I think I think we
had a very productive conversation in
fact we disagree about very little it's
more a matter of emphasis than anything
else his next book is about cruelty and
I strongly urged him to call it you know
in praise of cruelty yeah keep up that
contrary and banner but he I think he's
not gonna do that
good so as you say you have an interest
in both the social sciences and the
Natural Sciences and through your
research and through study you've come
to this the social sweet this list of
common qualities that people have in
their social lives and that that we can
help to use these explain how cultures
evolve but there's an obstacle to being
a good social scientist which is that
you don't have a human being version of
the particle accelerator right you can't
do controlled experiments quite as well
or like yes exactly or like oh you don't
have you have either observatories nor
colliders so what do you do I mean you
look at societies that exist but of
course there's it's hard to find a
control group there but you have some a
couple of ingenious chapters on ways in
which we
have more or less isolated experiments
with human societies well first of all
in my lab we and in many labs of course
we do do experiments Franck experiments
and you know one of the things we've
done is we've written some software
though that's integrated with online
labor markets and we can recruit tens we
have recruited tens of thousands of
people that come and participate in our
experiments and in a god-like way you
can randomly assign them to different
treatments and actually this was very
much motivated by my own background or
education in the Natural Sciences you
know we take for granted you know many
of us remember from high school physics
the incline playing experiment where you
vary the angle theta you put the weight
on in the new track you know that the
far it goes and eventually you learn
about friction and static and dynamic
friction and separate so all the classic
stuff for chemistry you know where the
teacher would sit in the front and
titrate the red and blue and you would
get it or in biology you would dissect a
frog and get a like sciatic nerve
preparations for electrical stimulation
see the muscles contract and there
hasn't really been an analogous way of
doing that kind of pedagogy in the
social sciences so party for research
purposes partly for pedagogical purposes
we have developed a kind of software
that allows us to devise an experiment
in the morning - you call it breadboard
because it's modeled after those those
other things many of us remember from
high school where you would build
electrical circuits on a breadboard with
interchangeable components you know
resistors and capacitors and batteries
and like switch the light bulb goes off
it's amazing so uh so our vision was
that there would be interchangeable
social components you might manipulate
the topology of the network into which
people were placed or you might
manipulate the directionality of the
ties and the payoff matrix or the
information quality how much noise was
there in the communication or the wealth
endowments of the individuals so all of
these social properties could be
manipulated and you could create these
artificial societies and and then
experimentally
change them and see what happens
consistent with theoretical predictions
so we've done a lot of that work and
that isn't a book but but I kind of put
the cart before the horse let me tell
you before the real experiments some of
the natural experiments which is I think
what
asking about I mean I love your real
experiments for the natural experiments
are even cooler yeah well this is the
thing you know this goes back maybe have
a bigger conversation about causal
inference you know I I like to invoke
physics models because it's often you
know people say well this work is
sometimes a criticism of some work in
the social sciences is is that it's sort
of a theoretical where it's you
literally merely observational well you
know Galileo's discovery of the moons
around Jupiter was merely observational
you know and or they'll say this is
observational not experimental we can't
be sure well as for physics you know
there's limited experimentation
absolutely mean it's beautiful
complicated work that relies on
observation and theory and computation
so so those those critiques in and of
themselves I don't think conceptually
have much bearing but I will admit that
a lot of the work that's done is not you
know not a very high level or quality
but it's the proper fatique of those
works I don't think is that they simply
are observational rather than
experimental anyway so for experiments
so what so in an ideal world at least
you know from my mad scientist point of
view what we would love to do is take a
group of babies that were a cultural
that is to say had no cultural
upbringing or exposure and abandon them
on an island and let them grow up and
then come back you know 30 or 40 years
later and see what kind of society did
they make now we're talking now this is
the scientific brain at work yes yes
exactly exactly okay this would be this
would be exactly the kind of experiment
I'll do the fight to do it is that you
know is this just obviously cruel and
unethical and yeah but it hasn't stopped
people from thinking about it for
thousands of years you know it's been
called the forbidden experiment Bob so
there's an official title for this this
is something that people fantasize about
yes at drinks at sociology conferences
sociology is monarchs
so Herodotus talks about an Egyptian
pharaoh who was very interested in
was the first language that people spoke
what language what was in our brains
it's actually an interesting question
that is where our powerful person might
have thought of thousands of years ago
and so what he did was he took two
babies and gave them to a mute chequered
to be raised up in the mountains to see
what language did they make if they were
never exposed to any language obviously
an awful cruel experiment and and may
not may not yeah but but that give them
data yes exactly but some European
monarchs also in the you know beginning
of 1100 and later also thought about
this experiment they they framed into
more religious terms you know what
language did out of a Neve speak so they
wanted to you know take babies and do
say experiment and so it's been
contemplated and sometimes allegedly gun
but it's obviously forbidden so so
instead what I look for some natural
experiments in one class of natural
experiment what was unintentional
communities that were formed in the wake
of shipwrecks so a group of people who
were did choose to be we're just sort of
grabbed and dropped on an island and who
spent who or at least 19 people that's I
pick as a threshold and who said at
least two months there and then what can
we learn from what kind of social order
they made did they cooperate do they
have hierarchy today did they befriend
each other and do they teach each other
things for example that were their
divisions and what were the implications
of the presence or absence of those
features for the ability of the group to
survive for example which is a nice
objective function you know do the group
if you can hear and eventually some of
them had to be rescued so that we could
hear the results of these experiments
correct and in fact there's some famous
very famous cases where we're present
with my most favourite case so yeah so
what further necessary criterion for
this is that yes there can be a
supernova but the light might never hit
the earth and so we we never see it so
we would need so we need one at least
one person to survive to tell the tale
otherwise the you know we never earth we
would never notice
happen so so one famous example where
that didn't happen is it was a shipwreck
where a large group of people I don't
remember the details at the moment
except I remember the crucial detail
which is they managed to capture some
kind of huge bird I think a petrol they
were in the South Pacific and they
attached to this bird's leg a message in
a bottle like a little capsule with a
note identifying where they were their
coordinates who they were that they were
the know the the shipwrecked crew of
such-and-such a vessel and they attach
it to this bird which bird them through
thousands of miles and was found in
Australia a few couple of years later
and and the message was found in red and
an expedition was sent to actually find
these men and by the time the exhibition
got there and the men were all gone they
were dead it was felt that they had
somehow sailed to another Island because
there was no evidence of their bodies
but um so obviously we don't know what
happened with that crew but it's an
amazing that tend to communicate know so
we need someone to survive and what I
did was is there about 9,000 shipwrecks
between not ships lost at sea ships that
wrecked on a coast between 1500 and 1900
and and I found 20 of them that meet
these criteria at least 19 people living
for at least two months often per year
or more and often larger groups 50 or
more people and I've got all of the old
records the the you know the through
journals that they kept and also any of
modern archaeological excavations and
try to get a sense of what do these
people do how do they organize their
societies and but that wasn't the only
kind of evidence you know I looked at
the settlement of Polynesia
you know the Polynesian expansion when
the ancient Polynesians spread out over
the Pacific and populated all these
islands
I looked not only unintentional
experiments but also at intentional
experiments at de communes in the 19th
century where people set off to you know
make a utopian community and even since
Roman times people have been doing this
they've been saying this society sucks
you know let's go make our own site and
off they go
and in the 1960s and 70s they were
communal with the United States to
bookses in Israel or where I looked at
settlements of scientists you know in
Antarctica on the South Pole since the
1950s the American station in the South
Pole has had groups of scientists that
and technicians that which are over so
again isolated population have to
organize themselves in some way what did
they do and then these are all these are
all made by people who of course come
from our actual society yeah it's not
the forbidden experiment quite but
you're at least gonna ask how they might
diverge correctly they choose to be
their solution all their and culture
they're adults there are lots of
problems that make it not ideal as an
experiment but here again you know I
used some of the examples you know I I
borrow some against some physics
metaphors the fact that you know the
telescope that Galileo used was really
crude and he was able to see a lot with
this tell ya you know the absence of a
Hubble doesn't mean you know that we
should look down on a more primitive way
of understanding or preliminary way of
understanding the world so yes are there
is there so there's light interference
and atmosphere interference and there's
noise and our equipment isn't perfect
but we can still see something when we
look at these these unintentional and
intentional communities and the last
thing which I mentioned earlier was I
collected data about artificial
communities you know either your online
worlds like World of Warcraft or other
massively multiplayer online games or
our own experiments or where the
experiments of other scientists that
have done these artificial experiments
where they create groups and manipulate
them including into them in some of our
groups where we replace some people with
forms of AI you know bot so we we create
hybrid systems of humans and machines
and replace some people with
programmable agents and then we can
really test what's happening get
complete control over that agent right
so anyway so you look at all of this
evidence and then just sum up or yeah
yeah no well yeah much we could easily
spend two hours just telling stories of
these shipwrecks so let's just encourage
everyone to buy the book yeah there's
some great stories about shipwrecks in
there I mean maybe mention just the one
Island that had two shipwrecks on it
I'll come back to that yeah okay see but
just but just to sum up so this so that
sub challenge becomes so you have all of
this data from different sources but one
way to think about this is to imagine a
kind of a hyperspace let's let's imagine
it's three-dimensional space where you
can you have actions that are defined by
for example how large is a face-to-face
community that is to say how much can
each how many unique individuals can
each person befriend and that number
could go from zero to a thousand let's
say you can imagine a creature like ours
that could have a thousand real friends
you know most of us have three or four
or five meal close intimate personal
relationships and then you can imagine a
society which you array how cooperative
they are that is to say on a one-off
game how likely are they to cooperate
with a stranger and that probability
could go from zero to one and then you
can imagine a society in which another
axis which define how unequally is the
wealth distributed in that society from
again zero up to one you know all the
wealth belongs to one person or all the
wealth is equally shared let's say so
those like to be three or of course you
could have more axes and when you do
that kind of an exercise and you what
you find is that all human societies
that have ever arisen occupied a small
fraction of that Morpho space there
they're all clustered in a little tiny
region and and if you look at all the
evidence from the unintentional and
intentional and artificial societies
they'll all again and again that fest
these same quality so there's a kind of
universe there's a kind of way in which
we only manifest as small it seeming
seems like a lot of variation but it's
actually not in this yellow region of
this space and so then that questions
become oh how and why did that come to
be how to and why the natural selection
constrain us to be you know just here is
it easy to summarize what that space is
well it depends on it depends on which
axes you pick how many axes you allow I
use some examples from other animals I
use the examples I borrow actually some
of Richard Dawkins ideas from even older
work in the nineteen sixties on shell
shape morphology so if you're trying to
get a set of mathematical equations that
define all possible shells that could
ever arise it turns out and can
summarize these shells with either three
or or eleven parameters
you can talk about that these are the
kinds of shells that snails crawl around
in yes exactly yeah and you can and you
find that only certain shells that could
ever potentially have arisen have arisen
and you know why is that
is that because for example it was
impossible for natural selection even to
give rise to such cells or is it that
there is no shell outside this cluster
that is fit in any modern or any
environment that has ever existed and
and so the argument by analogy is that
something similar happens with human
societies that there are no other kinds
of societies that would make sense to
make and further evidence of that is in
the book and I look at animal societies
like elephants and and whales and I find
that this social suite that we find in
humans also is in elephants for instance
in the elements you know that we our
last common ancestor with elephants was
85 million years ago we have died in
independent evolution you know converged
on the same solution just like just like
two species might independently converge
on an eye we have indeed because there's
only you know there's only certain ways
you can make a camera type eye then we
can see the light Liam you know there's
only certain ways you can live socially
pure mammal and we find that again and
again hey we want to talk about that
what should example or I don't know
where I don't know well III I think that
I just want if it's possible yeah I get
that there's this large parameter space
of how the societies could have evolved
and clearly the evidence is that we
don't randomly fill up that parameter
space right we stick to certain
commonalities and even the elephants
stick to these commonalities
so there's clearly something beneficial
and selected about some aspects of the
social sweet the love and friendship and
and social cooperation and so forth but
so the actual communities that you talk
about though seem to at least on the
face of it turn out very differently
from time to time so is there a simple
way of understanding what the
commonalities are or is it just that
there's certain there's more than one
way but still to be a society but still
far fewer than all the ones we could
imagine
well I mean I'm not sure I fully
understand your question but let me I
think I did so let me give two
potentially just responsive answer beats
so one question you might one way to be
free you see if your question is well
sometimes our mutants you know like your
body is programmed to to to do certain
things to have have a certain height or
make insulin in a certain way and maybe
you have a mutation that makes you not
capable of making insulin so you get
diabetes so and that's not as fit let's
say for the environment in which we live
and and but that but that that that
mutation is no no more an illustration
of the ordinary structure and function
of the human body that is to say there's
something that pushes you away from
let's say the ordinary structure and
this is the thing that's in your genes
its biological and of course there can
be environmental things so for example
if you have a group of children and you
starve them they don't grow up to have
bodies they might be actually more prone
to diabetes in adulthood and they might
also have stunted growth and in both of
these cases you know the intrinsic let's
say mutation or the environmental
constraint we would not think of we
would say those have have caused a
swerving away from what was otherwise
predestined to occur that otherwise
would have been the same normal quote
unquote
so now of course I'm I realize that
sometimes these mutations actually are
beneficial in fact that's how evolution
works but for now I'm just at one
cultivating this notion that there's
something that could normally would
occur but for what intrinsic or
endogenous or exogenous reason you've
been pushed away from it well the same
argument I would make about societies
there's a kind of inborn society but
sometimes we're unable to realize that
for example it in times of scarcity if
there's no if there's not enough food in
the environment we might fall upon each
other and eat each other now we should
do that in fact some evidence in the
book suggests that if we cooperate we're
more likely to survive but I would argue
that that's the the society that humans
make in a in a moment of scarcity that
is to say when there is no no food at
all are you
is it's no more illustrative of the
society humans would actually make if
they had our resources then the body you
make if you have been raised in scarcity
is a lustrum of the body you would make
it there was no scarcity so I'm trying
to get at the kind of natural you know
sort of innate thing you would have done
yeah without constraint so why don't you
talk about that the island example I
think this is a good test case for these
ideas where you had two different
shipwrecks more or less overlapping in
time ya know about each other with that
case it's the only such case that I'm
aware of where in about 1846 there were
in the South Auckland island south of
New Zealand slightly north of Antarctica
the there were two shipwrecks at the
same time in the same place on this
island and they spent over a year there
one crew was almost two years one crew
was just over a year and they overlapped
for about a year and they did not know
about each other's presents there's some
hint in one of the Diaries that they saw
some smoke in the distance one day and
they went to the smoke and they they
didn't they almost met I mean they
almost met I think think I've ever
watched lost I did I thought you have a
quiz applause yes you know it that's
what it is yeah it was actually it was
Sean Carroll in a bunker underneath you
know why the others yeah story and and
and they and they and they were
different it was very interesting the
difference so in one rep the Grafton
actually the graph that I had to relax
my standards a little bit there were
only five members of the crew whereas in
the in Vercoe which which wrecked on the
northern part of the island the Grafton
worked on the southern part the Enrico
had 19 people so the Grafton they on the
ship hits the shore and their foundry
and the captain had already been sick he
had a fever if he was in his cabin and
the ship is sinking
and the men the other men make it to
shore and they have to decide what to do
about the captain so they set up a rope
pulley system and at great risk to
themselves they ferry the captain ashore
so this this rep starts with the saving
of a life we
the people band together to save
someone's life and there are other
examples sacrifice yeah yes some risk
and some sacrifice and there are other
shipwrecks not this one where similar
things happen where for example there's
another case that I discuss where the
captain had a big big bag of gold in his
cabin and the crew were trying to rest
the gold and he told them not to rest of
the gold to rescue a girl who's drowning
instead and that and the gold was lost
but captain acted this way and I think
that type of activity sets the tone
right for the group to understand we're
all in this together we're going to
quality would be the secret that's what
happens on the graphic in the end of
Rico the the ship atomizes much more
rapidly there's also slight difference
in salvage and other details of the two
crews the the the enrico hits the shore
and it's reduced to splinters within an
hour and nineteen men make it ashore and
they have they have a pencil either many
of them did they have no shoes you know
some of them arrived naked this is a
very common scenario the way the crew
would arrive naked literally on the
shore they write with it with a pencil
some matches which eventually dry and
they're able to light a fire a few days
later although they screw up and they
there they're trying to dry their
matches by the campfire and then they
ignite all of them oh no total disaster
but they got their first fire going and
uh and a couple of pounds of heart
attack and a couple of pounds of salted
pork that's their Salvage plus some
clothes and one of the people was
injured and there at the base of these
cliffs and they abandoned this man the
other 18 climb up they send an advance
party up that find some pigs that had
been had been previously set loose on
this island by other people decades
earlier wild pigs so they can see
there's some food up there and so
eighteen of them go and they abandoned
his men to die and that's the beginning
of the invar Co and ultimately all five
of the Grafton people survive and make
it off they sail away on their own and
only three of the 19 on the Enrico
survived and their cannibalism and
they're routinely abandoning their
weakest members it's a totally different
destiny so but what does that teach us
about the
you know the discussion between this
sort of determinism of the social sweet
pushing societies in a certain direction
versus the contingency of some
influential event early on leading to
later view percussions right well it's
again like I just invoke the analogy of
the body you know that your your body
has a set of the DNA programs your body
could be a certain way for example if my
program you to be very hairy but you
might shave your hair you know so
there's an environmental thing that
happens that makes you shave your hair
so notice but but uh you know or or
there's some cultures for example that
buying people's heads like South
American cultures to reshape their heads
so that the elites of this society we're
supposed to have a head that looked like
a boat it's called Scappoose eppley
sometimes babies are born this way
because the sutures of their cranium
don't fuse or prematurely fused and they
get a oblong head they thought it was
very beautiful so they would buying
children's heads to give them this
really kind of alien looking head shape
now that alien head shape is no moral uh
straight above the natural head shape
than anything else so so I would say an
out of this lead to what we're
discussing the even though there is an
innate type of society we are
predestined or pre-wired to make which
resembles other social mammals to
incidentally there are contingencies
that can swerve us away from it and
those can include poor leadership it can
include profound resource constraints
although often we see paradoxically one
of the arguments I make in the book is
that we are better able to meet our
needs for food and water and shelter it
used to be thought that you have to meet
those primary needs first before you
could manifest these more sublime
qualities like love and friendship and
self-actualization but I actually think
that in many ways you have that the
reverse actually meeting our needs for
friendship and cooperation first is what
actually allows us to to meet our other
more basic needs for food and shelter
and so forth so
and I think there's good evidence for
that so so anyway so there can be
contingencies of schwarber so wait for
it but I don't think those undermine the
claim that there is a kind of basic core
society that we're pre-wired to make
okay that makes sense actually you've
intrigued me now so what is this
evidence that love and friendship need
to come before food and water well so
we're not gonna run out of megabytes
here don't worry yeah yeah okay well I
mean I just mindful I mean like I'm
dying to ask you all these questions
about your own work and but I took
advantage of this opportunity and I feel
like I know it's part of the point Plan
B here view about the book but you know
right anyway we'll get there
okay so um I guess the basic point that
I would make is the following point in a
kind of broad high-level answer to your
question which is our species I think
has one of the broadest ranges on the
planet of any species maybe even broader
than ants or you know particular species
and we have aa do Wilson calls the
social conquest of the earth why why are
we able to live everywhere from the
equator to the Arctic from you know
deserts to to river to you know some
people are seafaring there are people
that literally never live on land they
spend their whole lives that I discussed
them in the book that so-called sea
nomads for example they always live at
sea and they forage for their food at
sea they literally hunt under water and
they have the best free divers in the
world actually they've evolved in some
ways in response to this this capacity
but anyway so why and why are we able to
do that the reason we're able to do that
is because of our capacity for culture
precisely because we evolved the
capacity to accumulate knowledge across
time and space and to distribute it
across time and space so that for
example you know a person born in the
United States today in high school
learns muffin cameron mathematics that
would have made him or her the most
sophisticated mathematician on the
planet 500 years ago actually as an
aside one thing that amazes me is that
Isaac Newton invented the calculus at
the speed at which we teach it which is
just mind-boggling
we're all amazed by that yeah yes just
unbelievable right the guy advanced
calculus in a year you know just just
incredible anyway so so so you argument
we are all the beneficiaries of all of
this knowledge that is been accumulated
you know the roads and the and the
smelting of metals and the agriculture
all the domesticated animals that our
ancestors domesticated and the knowledge
of the stars in the navigation
techniques and mathematics and actually
that spreads across the planet so it's
very rare that someone makes a private
discovery and no one ever else hears
about it you know it's disseminated and
we'd like to disseminate knowledge and
to learn from others where we've evolved
to do this so this capacity that we have
evolved for culture is in fact what
makes it possible for us to to live
everywhere in the world so I guess what
I'm saying but I'm not is long
digression to to explain you know there
are cultural animals and that this
equips us to to live in many different
environments is that that very variety
that we privileged and that we see is
actually a quality that we evolved to
have that capacity to manifest culture
and to be animals that teach and learn
and that's the more primary and
fundamental ability that we have yeah
and you there's a wonderful example you
have in the book of the fact that human
faces exhibit a lot more variety than
faces of a lot of other animals and part
of that is how we identify each other
right yes well that's another kind of
paradox there's likely some paradoxes
when you think about human social living
the the the capacity to be individuals
it is itself lies at the core of our
capacity to live socially so so we have
evolved the ability to signal our
individuality we do it with our faces
every human face is different and the
regions of our genome that are
responsible for the shape and appearance
of our faces are highly variable for a
person you know from person to person
where
the region of your genome that makes
insulin you know is roughly the same I
mean there are differences but roughly
the same where's a region of our genome
that makes our faces is very different
and gives rise to differently shaped in
faces in all kinds of ways furthermore
each feature of our face is uncorrelated
with every other feature for example if
you look at your hands people with
longer hands also have wider hands and
there's like one parameter that is hand
size whereas if you look at for instance
the width of someone's nose people with
wider noses are not necessarily people
with taller noses those two properties
are uncorrelated in our face precisely
because we want as many combinations
possible of all the features of our face
to give the most variety in our faces
and not only do we have this capacity
which is actually uncommon in animals
and as an evolutionary luxury we also
have the cognitive capacity to tell the
difference so you can look at it a sea
of faces and see that everyone's face is
different and this also is an
evolutionary luxury so so both of these
qualities the ability to signal your
identity and the ability to detect the
identity of others are unusual among
animals and are expensive our
evolutionarily expensive you almost
brainpower that needs to be engineered
to be able to do this then and but
they're essential for living socially
and the reason there are sensible living
socially is you have to first be able to
identify specific other individuals if
you're to be able to tell who's a friend
and who's an enemy or who's my child
that I should actually give food to as a
pair just a stranger's child that I
shouldn't necessarily raise or who
cooperated with me in the past and I
need to reciprocate their kindness so so
we've involved this capacity for our
individual identity that is essential
for our ability to live socially and I
we have our faces but for me that was a
little insight a big insight I got from
the book you know is one of these things
you take for granted of him of course I
know different individuals and I have
different relationships with different
individuals but maybe elsewhere in the
animal or the plant kingdoms for that
matter those differentiations are not
quite as obvious the idea of friendship
and having a social network you talk
about a lot in the book is it is it
really that differ
between human beings and other animal
species friendship well it's very
different so first of all many animals
evolved to reproduce sexually so you
know we it's not uncommon that we form
and many animals also evolved to
reproduce sexually with the same mate
across time to have a kind of monotony
but we don't just reaper don't just mate
with each other we befriend each other
before our like long term non
reproductive unions to other members of
our species and that's very rare we have
friends that's rare in the animal
kingdom to have any sustain relations
with non kin unrelated individuals we do
it elephants do it a certain cetaceans
do it orcas defends certain other
primates do it it's very rare
some people face a dog's you know wild
dogs do it but that's not they might but
it's not exactly right because packs of
dogs often are genetically related your
cousins and so forth like I was when
thinking when reading that part of the
book I certainly thought about pets
right I mean dogs and cats in some sense
bond with their owners do they bond with
their owners more than with other dogs
and cats well that's another whole topic
the domesticated animals and our
friendships with those animals which I
actually use some examples in the book
of that and I think in some ways what's
happening there is our innate desire for
friendship and sociability is being
applied to and met by our relationships
to these animals now often we
domesticate animals that are quite
social on their own so so horses you
know live in herds and dogs with impacts
and those animals already neatly even
birds you know fly in flocks those
animals innately already have a sense of
interacting with others not always you
know some people keep pet lizards for
instance and we we do this as I said at
certain other social mammals do it it's
not the same in the you social insects
so ants and termites and you know what
they're all clones right they're all
genetically the same so it's not so
special that one can't will
another is its again a twin you know
yeah it's much more difficult to provide
an account for why we do that and we do
and the evolution of friendship is is is
profound
actually and very interesting and it
occurs as I said not just in US but in
certain other animals and and maybe is
from my extremely anthropocentric point
of view mice I should I think I'm
surprised that friendship isn't more
common in the animal kingdom I mean it's
we take it so much for granted that we
have different kinds of relationships
with other different humans it why it
shocks me that it's not more similar in
other you know at least in mammalian
species let's say right well it would
have to in order for a to evolve it
would have to meet a need right we have
to serve some purpose and and in Part II
but you would have to have the
availability of strangers you have to
live in groups to start with so the
first order first order criteria is that
there has to be a group of animals a
solitary animal would be unlikely let's
say to evolve the capacity to befriend
another solitary animal and occasionally
ran into for instance so so you'd have
to have first group living animals and
then the further evolution of this
capacity to form long term
non-reproductive unions to unrelated
individuals again it's not hard to
explain I mean it was challenging but
scientists have done this you know why
might you help your cousins well you
know there's chinna selection and
arguments from evolution why the
evolution of altruism towards your even
life-risking altruism towards your
relatives makes sense but why would you
willingly give to your friends and
there's a set of arguments about why
that might be the case one argument has
to do with the fact that the the
evolution of the ability to help people
in need
when it doesn't cost you very much is is
very valuable so if you think about what
friends do for each other we often do
each other favors of different kinds or
we help each other and provide emotional
support and and we do that in a way that
is not strictly reciprocated it's not
like I'll scratch your back now you'll
scratch my back tomorrow it's done in
this
unconditional way and that's an
enormously valuable type of relationship
to have in a social system where where
someone is drowning and it doesn't cost
you much to lower a branch so that you
to them so that they can be saved this
this outras up to an unrelated
individual could be extremely useful if
such an effort to evolve and and so
there's a set of ideas that that john
tooby aleena because meetings have
argued correctly in my view about the
evolution of friendship and in russia as
well Donald Russia also makes these
arguments is there some relationship to
language it would seem to me that once
individuals became better more adept at
speaking and communicating and agreeing
and negotiating in more subtle ways then
it would become more useful to have a
higher level of differentiation in our
relationships between different people I
think there's probably a deep
relationship between the evolution of
language and and the the the evolution
of friendship and actually even group
dynamics some people have argued I mean
Robin Dunbar has argued that that our
capacity for language involved in parts
to be a kind of efficient oral grooming
so so chimpanzees will groom each other
so one will groom the other maybe
they'll take turns or whatever maybe
they'll form a little circle but it's
all dyadic you can only groom one other
animal at a time but a group of humans
can sit in a circle and talk to each
other and I can give you five people
something of value not just one person
using language so I can it's a kind of
it's a kind of this transmission of
information it's a kind of kind of
grooming a kind of hype you know way in
which you can talk to multiple people at
once okay yeah that's that's coolants
and to study these I mean I do want to
let the audience know you you have all
sorts of little diagrams of networks in
your book the social networks because we
did I did have a podcast with Steven
Strogatz
yeah I'm studies networks
a purely mathematical point of view and
so you've been able to uncover sort of
things about the structure of friendship
by these network diagrams yeah I mean
you know Steve is a giant in the field
the the we use various sort of
mathematical tools and analytic tools to
to map out these networks and and and
and to you know trace out the topology
of these graphs and and summarize them
and analyze them in various sorts of
ways and there are a number of
interesting properties that arise and
you look at that one one set of ideas
has to do with the fact that when you
well there's several ideas let me write
them down somewhere else I'm going to
forget them yeah networks worldwide I
wrote a very long book I know and then I
started one of the things that happens
is is that I I get overexcited and then
I climb up a tree and then I go out on a
branch and I going on a twig and then I
fall off and I don't know where the tree
is anymore I know how it is yeah do you
have a deadline for how long we can talk
by the way okay good let's go I'm
worried that I'm being too loquacious
and so all right okay so so on the
networks out there when we begin to use
these tools to map networks you can make
a number of discoveries I mean first of
all you can ask yourself measures have a
following question which i think is
still not completely answered although
I've been spending a lot of time in my
laboratory trying to answer it which is
you can imagine let's say you're 100
people and you have the boundary
conditions are a null set where no one
is connected to anyone else or a fully
saturated graph for your n times n minus
1/2 connections and of course everywhere
in between you could have all these
other possible networks okay well when
you go out into these networks and
they're very interesting properties you
know mathematical properties and you can
go out into the world and you map
networks and you find again and again
that human beings make a particular kind
of network and then you can say well I
make this kind of network as compared to
any other topology for example human
beings manifest something known as
degree of sort activity that is to say
that highly connected nodes are
preferentially attached to other highly
connected nodes this is the opposite of
an airport network in an airport Network
degree dis assorted tivity so you have
hubs like Denver and Chicago and New
York that are connected to lots of small
airports but the small airports are not
connected to each other you can't fly
from Lebanon New Hampshire to New Haven
Connecticut you have to go you know from
Lebanon New Hampshire to Boston and then
from Boston to New Haven or to
Philadelphia where so degree assorted
networks are networks in which highly
connected individuals are connected to
highly so very popular people to friend
popular people and unpopular people to
friend unpopular people so you might ask
why do we do that right now it's very
interesting it turns out that degree of
sorted networks confer on a population
and a relative immunity to epidemic
diseases so in a degree it's a sort of
network if an epidemic of a bioterrorist
strikes one city in the next hop people
will go from that city to Denver and the
next day everyone else in the whole
country will be affected because people
fly out from Denver in a degree
disoriented network if the if the if the
epidemic begins stochastically and it
begins at random somewhere in the graph
only if it happens to strike one of
these few nodes that is high degree will
it spread to everyone otherwise the
epidemic will tend to be localized
within a particular region of the
network for instance among unpopular
people just getting the germs of the few
other unpopular people so it takes a
much longer for the epidemic to spread
so I don't think it's a coincidence that
of all the ways we could have come to
organize our networks we have organized
them to have this property of degree a
sort of tivity I think natural selection
has played a role and this touches on
very contentious issues having to do
with multi-level selection and other
topics but the gist is of all the
possible networks we could arrange we
have networks that have this property
and many other interesting properties
like for instance we have highly
transitive Network that is to say your
friends are very likely to be friends
with each other
much more likely than a random graph
with a similar number of ties in a
similar number of nodes and and this
transitivity also confers certain
advantages for group coherence and
cooperation and so forth so so the first
thing
like to say about these grasses when you
do these graphs and you mathematically
summarize these networks you make a
number of observations about the types
of graphs people make from all
imaginable graphs and then I don't think
it's a Jeff so story you observe that
some of those properties that you can
characterize have benefits and I they
have those benefits precisely because
natural selection has worked on us to
give us those benefits first point yeah
I owe that was your first point okay let
me make two little quick sub points I
know this is gonna be an expanding guy
ok good so here my two little sub points
one is I think it it makes sense to me
that the graphs like this are chosen by
natural selection but on the other hand
it's not obvious because maybe there's a
physical making the graphs mechanism
that naturally just easily leads to
graphs like this and we're just lucky
that it's also very useful I would love
to get evidence that points one way or
the other the second point is that the
robustness of this kind of network
structure I think is a wonderful lesson
for human beings who intelligently
design networks in computers or on the
internet or in their electrical grids
that aren't nearly as robust as the ones
that nature builds and is often because
you know we try to imagine what the
threats are ahead of time and we're not
very good at that
whereas natural selection just sort of
has put up with a whole bunch of
unpredictable threats and generates
therefore a very generally robust way of
dealing with them yes and so yes do you
want me to comment on them or just say
no if you say yes that's great
points so um so so that was that was the
first point that I was making was about
why we have this particular topology of
all the possible topologies the second
point is that when you go out therefore
into the world and you map these
networks this we have and we've sent
teams to uganda and india and honduras
the united states and various other
places around the world Sudan you map
these networks you find that these
networks again and again have a very
similar architecture a very similar
topology and I find that amazing
that you can go all over the planet and
people befriend each other and each
person is exercising their predestiny
too you know befriend each other and
then you settle ourselves into this into
this this structure like ant colonies
you know like ant hills where we
reproducibly make again and again this
type of characteristic structure so the
second thing I would say is that first
point is that we make a particular kind
of network second as we always do it
there's some tolerance but again again
we produce these types of networks and
the third thing I would say is that
amazingly other social mammals make
networks with very similar topological
properties so earlier we talked about
transitivity that transitivity of
elephant networks is very dolphin
networks is very similar to our own but
why should it be that the friend of a
friend among dolphins is your is the
Dolphins friend and a friend of a friend
of mine elephants is the elephant's
friend and a friend of a friend among
humans is a human's friend well because
you know yeah and it's clearly evolved
independently because again you know our
last common ancestor was tens of years
ago and was a non social creature so so
I think these are all things of the all
three of these points relate to the
issue of the universality of networks
and their function in our lives yeah no
I think that it is fascinating feature
because it is one of these things where
everyone investigating this is a human
being and therefore grows up as a human
being and tends to take certain things
for granted and it's amazing what we
learned that things could have been
different or didn't have to be this way
speaking of which there's not only
friendship but love which you talk about
in the book and love seems different
also it's also something that is at
least more often human than in other
animals by love we mean sort of romantic
attachment to your lifelong sexual
partner right and I love the I'd never
heard of the fact that there are some
societies that try to do away with it
they try to make reproduction purely
about you know or make sex purely about
reproduction and not let you fall in
love and yet as in Romeo and Juliet
people always try to get around that yes
yes so interesting to me
the it's a Yuna cultural Universal we
love our partners even in arranged
marriages so about a billion people live
in countries that practice primarily
arranged marriages many many tens or
hundreds of millions of people meet
they're not only met their spouse once
or twice before they marry them and go
home with them and start having sex with
them and raise a family with them and
make a life with each other and
amazingly when you may use various
metrics like the passionate love scale
or you look at like divorce rates the
divorce rates are lower in arranged
marriages for a number of reasons but
including cultural constraints but yeah
but but but the sentiment of love so
even in those societies that have
arranged marriages while love before
marriage is seen as a threat and not
let's say the best way to organize how
people should choose each other love
after marriage is very much seen as a
desired property everyone thinks you
should fall in love with the person I've
chosen for you to marry so so so this is
a cultural Universal to this this fact
that we love our mates but you have a
source of why I mean we could be a
species that reproduces without loving
your mates but most do right yeah mostly
she's not not all species so so this is
what we're discussing here is a kind of
attachment that survives a single sexual
encounter a kind of sustained attachment
which in our species we experience is
love it's a it's a it's a kind of
sentimental feeling and a emotional bond
and a social bond to the people with
whom we have sex now not every person
has it all the time of course you can
have sex without being in love you can
be in love without having sex you know
it doesn't have to be strength of course
gay couples love each other so it's not
linked to reproduction and our species
which itself is interesting so all of
these things are true but the core is
that we love we have this capacity to
love the people that we are having sex
with and/or feel attached to them and
this is this type of social monogamy
this sort of sensibility is seen in
certain other like 90 percent of birds
or socially monogamous they mate for
life as it were they become attached to
their partners and certain other mammals
and it's seen universally in humans and
I think it's very interesting but as you
said there's some exceptions so there's
one one people the nod people in the
Himalayas
who organized their society they have a
strong cultural overlay like we were
discussing earlier the way certain
historical contingencies can swerve you
away from the innate they have a very
powerful over language is organized to
prevent couples from feeling affection
for each other and for example it's not
uncommon for women with a matrilineal
Society the the men will go trawling for
sex in the evenings the women will stay
at home the young men and older men will
knock it fences and say have sex with me
tonight have sex with me tonight the
woman will make a choice she'll say ok
I'll have sex with you and they might
have a kind of a fleeting relationship
for a number of days or weeks or a year
she could have more than one at a time
if she wanted and the boys that are
rejected they are not supposed to feel
rejected or jealous their friends will
mock them they'll say there's another
girl in the other village or down the
street right you know why are you
feeling this way you shouldn't feel
attached you know stop it don't feel
attached just actually someone else and
and there's mockery of people who have
sexual jealousy and and and it's not
uncommon for women in these villages to
have sex with every other man in that
village or every other village of their
cohort Fritz's now in this uneven in
this society some couples for them the
forbidden fruit is to be in love and if
they able fall in love and say we're
running away to be in love to just be
together
crazy rebels that there are rebels that
they are exactly I just don't have sex
with you I want to love you and I can't
help it show so um so and this this is
to my knowledge the only society has
organized this way it Marco Polo writes
encountered it and writes about it the
Chinese Communist Party thought that
this like sancious behavior was sapping
productivity and eat it he stamped out
he's worked whap out they would think
that yes and they tried to stamp it out
but they couldn't anyway they still
practice they still have this type of
traditional order among the NA so is
there uh give I mean the social sweet
that you talk about you know you're
eight factors one of them is love is
there a particular
explanation I know there's always a
danger of the just-so stories but can
you come up with a theory at least as to
why love goes along with these other
properties that are that seem not maybe
uniquely but especially human well
there's we don't know exactly why we
evolved the capacities for love it the
leading candidate is that attachment of
the attachment females feel to their
male partners in males feel to their
female partners because most of the
evolutionary force was acting on Etro
sexual unions the that capacity must
have served a purpose and one set of
ideas have to do with enhancing the
prospects of survival the offspring that
children have you better better life
deserve surviving especially in any
cultural animal like ours that needs to
be talked when the parents stick around
when both parents stick around now we're
not the old penguins do the same thing
by the way so we're not the only animal
that has by parental care but um but
attachment seems to be essential for
that that to happen
the male needs to feel like that the any
contributions he's making to the rearing
of these children are are his and oh and
one way to do that is by the female of
the species Telegraph and I'm attached
to you in other words if you see that I
love you you know these are your
children but as soon as you say penguins
do it too I mean that sort of gives the
game away because there's thousands of
species out there and it's not like they
mostly do it it's like we have to kind
of go pretty far in the evolutionary
tree to find others that do it the same
way
yeah well 90% of birds mate for life so
it's very common in the birds okay
that's but yeah but but it's very
uncommon in mammals incidentally and and
also I should be very careful to
emphasize it what's important here is
the attachment not the number of
partners so for instance were so
polygynous and Polly and rift societies
also have love right so it's not it's
not about having one partner it's about
the extra feeling you have about the
partner you're having sex with yeah it's
not it's not purely reproductive on the
motion
attachment as well yeah well okay so
these are the good aspects we talked
about you know friendship and
cooperation and love
now among your eight factors in the
social suite there's one that is
in-group bias and there's another one
that is mild hierarchy so you say mild
hierarchies you're both you want your
little ma hierarchy but you want your
cake and eat it too not too much
hierarchy right how do you fit these two
factors in which might seem a little bit
less obviously peace and love and
understanding in with the other ones
well well these qualities which
superficially might seem to be
disadvantageous you know like this this
in-group bias for example this
preference we have for us over them
which is a human which is innate it's
part of our nature it's a universal it's
it's actually very depressing to me that
we you know that we are in this way it's
part of our nature even this quality has
evolved in order to support our capacity
for cooperation so it is one of the most
robust psychological findings right I
think that you mentioned in the book and
there's also a study that came out very
recently where you give children
completely arbitrary markers of you're
in this group and you're in that group
and instantly they favor the people in
their group not the other one I know
it's really depressing isn't it you can
randomly assign you know children to
t-shirts three-year-olds so blue in a
tree t-shirt you can test that they know
that it's chance they recognize it it's
not right it didn't do something to
deserve this color and nevertheless with
this so-called minimal group this is
called the middle group paradigm you can
elicit from them all those green shirt
t-shirt children they're awful they
should be punished you know they they
should get any toys you know it's it's
awful right this is an off crew those
guys just a powerful part of our nature
honest but it's kind of a yeah I think
your argument is it's that awfulness is
kind of a spandrel it's kind of a side
effect of there's a goodness there's a
usefulness in group I yes that's exactly
right and that is involved to support
our capacity
for cooperation it's not the only tool
that has evolved to support our capacity
for cooperation but it's an important
one so in a way this in-group bias is a
tool to reduce the scale so imagine you
have a large population here and then in
the middle level you have groups and at
the bottom level you have individuals so
top level you have a huge population
middle level your groups us and then in
the bottom level you have individuals
the the capacity to draw the distinction
between us and them is going to be
essential to reduce the scale of the
people you need to cooperate with but
put your the large movements in
cooperate with everyone it's very hard
for cooperation to evolve and for you to
practice it but if I say just cooperate
with your group and you don't have to
partner with everyone else actually it
makes it easier for cooperation to
evolve in that type of a situation so
one of the theories about the evolution
of xenophobia or parochialism or
in-group bias is that it it makes it
possible for us to cooperate with each
other but I should say that it's not the
only thing the evolution of friendship
also meets that need because if you
think about friendship what friendship
does is it adds structure to a
population so instead of a well mixed
population you know sort of having
everyone is randomly interacting with
everyone else
a network imposes structure so each
person is interacting only with certain
other people but everyone has their own
alters everyone has someone they're
interacting with and now I just saw
you'd cooperate with your friends
everyone is cooperating just their
friends and so it reduces the scale by
adding structure to the population and
so that's another way to get cooperation
but in-group bias is one of them and and
it is it isn't depressing I mean it is
one of the most depressing you know
things that I have to think about
because because you know why you know
why can't we just have indifference to
the out-group you know must we hate it
right no why can't we just love our own
group okay fine let you love your own
group but you know you don't you don't
have to kill the other group you know
why should you just let them beat or
well you know we're we're recording this
podcast in the midst of the NBA Playoffs
and as a Sixers fan I can tell you that
you know Celtics fans are just not as
morally
has Sixers fans is that empirical
finding I wouldn't kill them but if they
were in distress I might pull out of my
way to help that's all but this is also
something where maybe this is the time
when it is worth mentioning that we can
talk about innate tendencies and and
things things that make us human but we
also have the cognitive capacities to
overcome them right now we can think
about how to shift our in-group IOC's
and change the focus as to where we put
our locus of care right the expanding
circle right so you know I think the way
I would say yes that's one tool at our
disposal is just to use our brains that
we have been endowed with to say ok this
is a part of our nature but you know I
have agency I don't have to you do this
thing correct but there's also other
tools that we could draw on so for
example earlier we imagined a
three-level model like the large
population the subgroups that are
defined you know subsets and then the
individuals one thing we can do is you
can you can go up a level and you can
use the capacity that we've been endowed
with to draw the boundaries these are
artificial boundaries in our groups we
say us and then we've said like the
t-shirts is an artificial boundary
instead what you can do is you can or
you know language or religion these are
artificial boundaries you can go up a
level and you can redefine the boundary
to be the whole group and if you think
about the American project for example
if you think politically about what ails
our society today there's a kind of over
identification of groups and a kind of
suspension of a commitment to the
American project and one of the things
that's amazing about our society is that
anyone can be an American we say if you
come to this country it doesn't matter
whether your ancestors were Greek or
Irish or Indian or whatever you can be
you are an American you just have to
accept our political principles you know
the Bill of Rights and our
constitutional government and you can be
an American other companies don't
necessarily do this by the way you know
it's very difficult because Swiss
citizen for example sure or Japanese
citizen but you can become an American
and so this has always been a part of
society you know the Tocqueville talks
about this extraordinary thing and what
it is in essence is you know a pluribus
you know you go up a level and you say
what really matters is we're all
American I think that one of the reasons
we have ascendance tribalism in our
society today is in part a side effect
of the collapse of the Soviet Union I
think when we had okay yeah when we were
all united against a common enemy I
think there was a bit more solidarity in
our society yes of course you had
political differences and I'm not I'm
not saying it was the best of all
possible worlds or but I think it's not
a coincidence that this record essence
of tribalism our society at this
historical moment follows closely out on
the heels of the you know the lack of
another superpower that we're kind of
trying to con man or respond so well we
should be hoping for is an invasion by
aliens yes a little humanity yes the
problem is those aliens I'm quite
convinced actually your opinion on this
I think those aliens would be just very
lucky to wipe us out I don't think
they'd be beneficent what do you think
you know yeah there's a well the way
that I would put it is we have no idea
but if there's a 5% chance that they
would wipe us out is that a risk worth
taking I mean let's put it this way we
have a very good idea that they could
wipe us if the guy yes yeah the chances
if we meet any alien civilization that
we would be able to put up a fair fight
are negligible so I would rather see the
human race try to figure stuff out for
themselves for a few more hundred
thousand years before we meet the aliens
personally yeah I mean I'm inclined to
agree with you you know like I leaving
out the fantasy that in a world of a
world situation you know they would be
infected by our bacteria and be wiped
out I think much more likely a species
that could reach our planet would treat
us with the same indifference that we
might stomp on an anthill if you cross
an ocean to go to another continent or
frankly that we saw with the
colonization of the south of South
America right I mean to the indigenous
peoples were just wiped out by the
Spaniards and so with just a difference
and so I I think well to be fair you
know there
the counter-argument to that which we
should put on the table which is that
maybe they don't well mate yeah well
maybe there's a threshold that species
cross into self-awareness a certain
level of cognitive capacity in
consciousness where they can use
language and have technology and so
forth and once you reach that you have a
sort an empathy and fellow feeling for
all the other species that feel likewise
now maybe not right yeah I mean okay how
are we treating the elephants on our
planet
well well hopefully we're getting better
we're terrible right I mean is obviously
the answer but maybe we're getting
better right like all of these things
are happening on such a rapid timescale
that you know if we're trying to ask
questions about well we will be doing a
thousand years from now it's almost
completely hopeless right so I'm not
saying we have figured it out but I'm
saying that there's a logical
possibility that we are in the process
of figuring it out and by the time the
aliens get here they will have figured
it out I mean that's what I used to
think and you know I would be happy to
follow your lead you know thinking what
you're saying but I increasingly am I'm
getting more we're I mean we're on a
tangent of a tangent right now but again
we're worried about I'm not so I mean
I'm sort of buying the Steven Hawkings
argument or you know that I used to
about this topic I knew the one who just
wrote a 500 page book but up and so we
were talking about penis but there's
another technique that evolution has
equipped us with which often is
overlooked and that's the capacity not
to step up and take advantage of our
ability to define groups but to step
down a level to the level of individuals
and so here the idea is is we have faced
the tribalism not by expanding the the
boundary but by decreasing the boundary
down to the individual level what we say
is that you should treat each other
person as an individual earlier we
talked about how we that we have the
capacity as an animal to uniquely
identify every other person and this too
has been a part of the our culture in
our society it's actually at the root of
what Martin Luther King argues when he
says he looks forward to a society where
we can people are judged by the content
of their character rather than the color
there's
saying each person should be judged as a
person not as a member of a group and
this also is a tool that evolution has
equipped us with and as it turns out in
my view provides an avenue out of the
tribalism that is afflicting us today
yeah
good that's a whole long maybe for the
next podcast when I have you on next
year again we'll discover some of these
because there's so many other things I
want to get to the hierarchy question
right you mild hierarchy is one of your
elements of the social sweet so this
seems to suggest that on the one hand
human beings like to have a little bit
of hierarchy but not too much is that a
fair gloss yes and again you have to ask
yourself why we evolved this there's
just scribble some notes really so I
don't go off the deep end again so why
do you need my authority again you can
imagine a parameter space of hierarchy
from you know complete absence of
hierarchy when everyone is absolutely
equal there no differential resources or
power let's say to a complete autocracy
you know where one person can completely
dominate other individuals and you'll
kill them at will let's say and and and
we we have a we're in the middle regime
that turns out as a primate species and
we have evolved this capacity for model
hierarchy hierarchy and mild hierarchy
is important because both extremes are
bad for us and a bad person rather in
rather specific ways first of all in the
absence of any hierarchy turns out that
there's some experiments that have been
done by Jessica flack and Santa Fe and
others where they've taken primate
species they've mapped on networks
they've identified the top dogs or the
top primates and they they have it's
permanently remove them from the network
what they find is is that chaos ensues
there's tremendous amount of fighting as
people jockey for power in position even
among the subordinate peripheral
individuals so one of the things that a
little hierarchy does is it taps down on
violence it keeps the peace it keeps
people from you know fighting with each
other in the dish
there's some evidence that a little bit
of hierarchy and here now I'm eating
when there's like popular individuals
with some people hundr regulates the
flow of information through the graph
and optimizes the flow of good things
and suppresses the flow of bad things so
you're saying the Walter Cronkite was
better than Twitter for spreading news
around yes actually that's a really good
example approximately but yes that's
right but if there's some kind of
central filter in the information so for
example and that this helps keep the
peace so so there's some evidence of
this role of mild hierarchy but in
addition we we humans have evolved two
different ways of communicating status
so there's two different kinds of ways
you can think about hierarchies or sort
of status in a society and one of them
has to do with dominance hierarchies and
many animals have this and this has to
do with the ability typically physical
ability of bigger animals to impose
their will on others these sort of
dominance hierarchy and you can think
about these as costs the costs that one
animal can impose on another animal so
the animal with bigger antlers your
bigger tusks for example can kill the
drive away the other animal and so
subordinates in those types of
hierarchies try to avoid the super
ordinance they because of a cost the
super ordinance can impose on them but
we humans have a parallel kind of
hierarchy which is based on prestige and
prestige hierarchies have to do with the
benefits that super ordinates can impose
on subordinates and because the super
hardness let's say have knowledge we are
smart so your graduate students I'm
assuming want to spend time with you
because of the benefits you can confer
upon them I'm assuming and wrap so they
believe they don't know but don't don't
tell everybody rather than avoid you
because of the cost that you can impose
on them these are prestige hierarchies
and in our species these often have to
do with cognitive abilities we can teach
each other things so we have two
parallel ways of having hierarchy in our
society roughly speaking the costs which
often are physical and the benefits
which often are confident that we can
distribute and if there's evidence for
both in our ancestral you know in our
evolution
but it's because of this connection to
prestige that my own hierarchy can be
beneficial the existence of people with
special knowledge that can distribute
these benefits to others is part of the
reason you want some of the mild
hierarchy know when you get it too much
but typically what we feel has happened
what's likely to happen we're not sure
is that some warmness probably resented
too much power going to some particular
individuals and probably banded together
and and killed them
Ashley and so one of the reasons we
think in our evolution we've been shaped
for a mild hierarchy is precisely for
this reason yeah so it seems as if I'm
really guess and you'll correct me if
I'm wrong that the thing about mild
parky is that is the best system for
various reasons and therefore maybe it
explains why we evolved to like it I
mean obviously there are examples in
history where we've gone to complete
autocracy and stratification or complete
anarchy and the Galit arianism but
there's some happy middle where you're
going to argue that we tend toward yes
arguing that there's evidence from other
social mammals that this is optimal
including experiments with primates so
that's right and it often has to do with
social animals that have the capacity
for teaching and learning that can
collect and distribute information that
you get these kind of counterbalancing
forces so basically instead of having
organizing the society against around a
dominance hierarchy now of a sudden you
need to reduce the ability of physically
very powerful individuals to to dominate
and to put this exactly it turns out
that one of the reasons it is felt that
we have mild hierarchy is that there's
been a kind of rough justice a kind of
rough calculus between dominance
hierarchies and prestige hierarchies and
that's why we wind up a little bit in
the middle range as i cought notable
that makes sense I mean all these you
know features of the social sweet from
identity love friendship hierarchy and
group bias you you want to say they're
not only there but you want to say their
genetic is
that they're built into our DNA somehow
is that mostly sort of circumstantial
you know what else could it be if it's
that Universal or is there something
there more directly genetic evidence
that we can point to for the the origins
of these features that sounds like
something to be very difficult at this
state this point in human history to
really establish well for some traits
there's quite a lot of evidence I mean
my lab has done a lot of work on the
genetics of friendship for example and
we've been able to show that that the
propensity for friendship some of the
higher-order structures we were
discussing earlier are partially
genetically encoded I mean there's no
doubt a rule for culture also and
nurture but there's clearly a world of
nature we've shown that the way you
choose your friends is partly shaped by
your genes you might be able to reason
by analogy and see like for example many
people are capable of love at first
sight it's not an uncommon phenomenon
you should have any intuition that that
love at first sight probably has
something to do with genes like that is
to say that you know that some kind of
optimal you know that some kind of
optimal you know that the partner choice
should be under under selection is not a
shocking claim in it and there's a lot
of evidence for that in animals for
example you experiment with that but I
would say friendship choice also is
under natural selection for analogous
reasons and and we have evidence for
this and so we there's evidence for that
there's also evidence for a partial
genetic basis for attachment for love
there's surprisingly little evidence so
far that we've been able to reduce for
the genetics of cooperation in our
species but we do have some such
evidence in other animals so it's again
doesn't strain credulity to me so we we
have level we have information on the
level of genes using a variety of
approaches that provide evidence for
this plus there's a comparative file o
genetic approach where for example we
find similar properties seen in other
animals or we can trace it out across
evolution so we can say when did social
monogamy appear in our species and we
see a very specific historical you know
evolutionary moment when that occurred
and we can trace out the branch
and this type of evidence also this
incident so there's lots of convergent
evidence that supports the claim that
many of these qualities are are you know
shaped by natural selection and
partially encoded in our genes but we're
not at the point yet where we could
actually point to a place in the genome
where oh this is a lot of treatments for
mild hierarchy or something like no
because these traits are so complex we
cannot even do that with height training
a risk and increasingly we're seeing
that many of these complex traits are
polygenic so the kind of thing we all
learned in high school biology about you
know about sickle cell disease or
polycythemia the monogenic mutations
that you know follow Mendelian
inheritance now those are the exceptions
actually most of the most of the forget
most of the behavioral and complex
traits we manifest even a lot of the
physical traits like yours it's a
prettier risk for your diabetes risk or
your height also are polygenic and we
barely understand you know we know there
are hundreds a couple hundred genes that
are responsible for height you know high
is very heritable but only one or two
percent of the variants to be explained
by known genes so something else is
going on and and that's being worked on
very actively I mean I think in our
lifetimes are likely to know the answers
to some of these questions I think it
has to do with the the combinatorial
complexity of the genes that is to say
it's not about which teams you have it's
about how they interact with each other
and furthermore of the temporal
unfolding so you might have five five
genes each of which has two variants the
precise sequence at which they turn on
and off mic determine how tall you are
even if you have the same variance in a
given individual and we don't know
anything about that yeah we know
somebody but we're learning more about
that yeah I think it's just important to
emphasize with a lot of people here that
something is genetic and they think oh
there's a gene for it that will align
the gene and we both know and I think
most of our listeners know it's way more
complicated than that so you can have
good evidence that something is
heritable as you say without having any
idea where it comes from in the DNA like
the facial like for example I'll give
you an interesting thing we're talking
about facial morphology there's one of
those famous examples in in
Lucian Area biology of something known
as an adaptive radiation which is from
an original species how many other
species evolved to fill in various
niches is Darwin's finches right so he
looks at all these peaks and he sees
that different animals have different
beaks
depending on what kind of food is
available on the island with those
finches from an ancestral population of
inches the finches on this island
involved eating nuts and the ones on
these Island tea flowers and they all
have different things and just recently
I think it was published in nature like
a couple of years ago the genetics and
this was worked out so we actually know
what are the genes that have variants
that affect the shape of the beak in
these animals you know something that
same gene affects our faces and and and
there's evidence that that same gene
plays a role in facial morphology in
humans so and I think I have the
footnotes to that in the book
so so I think I think you know we will
find for example increasingly the
genetic evidence for some of these
qualities including for example the
individual expression what do you think
are some of the we're winding down here
so what are the some of the normative
implications of what you're saying you
have a brief section in the book at the
end where you talk about morality for
example and I think this is a place
we're going to disagree because you seem
to be more sympathetic than I am to
somehow extracting some moral lessons
out of the facts about who we are and
how we got here
right so you know the moral philosophy
is a you know it's a attempt to provide
a kind of building up of moral
principles from axioms you know like
Euclidean geometry you know we start
with seven axioms I think it is I can't
remember and you know you get all
Euclidean geometry from some day you
know parallel lines continue
indefinitely and mechanistic level so
and but the moral philosophers have been
working for at least 50 years maybe more
and they have yet to uncover what these
universal you know what these
fundamental axioms that are universally
applicable are
and it's clear that moral philosophy
cannot be it's not about voting right
you don't like have everyone vote what's
right we know horrible you know things
that we would consider to be grossly
immoral like the killing of autistic
kids in Nazi Germany where you know
everyone thought that was fine above you
and I look at that I think that's just
clearly immoral so it's not about
majority rule or might make right it's
not about you know majority rule no wise
the Cardinals would have been correct
and Galileo would have been wrong so
that's not what determines whether
something is right is how many people
believe it it's not determined by who
whether powerful people espouse it so
there's a sense in moral philosophy that
there must be some kind of outside of
human ways that we could come up with
developing these moral principles now I
I am skeptical actually that that
project will succeed for a number of
reasons and in here I I share on a
shared Churchland perspective the
philosopher but uh but I do believe that
biology can help us help guide the way
as I argue a little bit in the book and
here I borrow some ideas from
philosopher Philippa flood where she
very famously says in moral philosophy
she said I think it's helpful to think
about plants which makes you think yes
yes I love philosophers it's just
incredible you know what she mean by
that exactly goes on to explain that
when you think about plants you can
think about whether a plant has good
roots and she says that you can speak of
this plant has good roots or bad roots
and what are good roots good roots are
the roots that make it possible to be a
plant and she also uses the example of
clocks she says you can speak of a good
clock or a bad clock and she says that a
good clock is one that tells time a bad
clock does not tell time so she makes an
argument about how while much of
morality is very contingent eventually
slipping and sliding it read me it meets
reality it meets the kind of foundation
and that there are you can develop moral
principles against constraints you can
speak of something that is
or bad given the constraints conditioned
on the constraints and so this is an
essence what I argue about human
societies given the need for us to live
together given that we are social
animals
what equips us with that and that's what
makes it good so our capacity for love
is good in that sense our capacity for
friendship is good in that sense and I
can't help but notice that many of these
qualities are good in the everyday
meeting as well if you ask people you
know if you we don't care if you love
yourself or are kind to yourself or are
or are just to yourself we care whether
you love others or kind to others or
just to others our virtues are social
virtues primarily and so we clearly have
a connection between that which we think
of as good a good life or good practice
or good behavior
much of that not all of it because we
also for example can think of bravery
facing a violent animal for example so
it's not social but we think of that as
a moral virtue you know most of our
virtues many of them are social in
nature so that's sort of the argument
that I I try to make you know at the end
of the book and why I think that is
possible to write at least a partially
biological foundation for morality yeah
so I would I mean I think what do you
sis that is extremely clear and
understandable and I don't quite go I'm
not quite on the train and the reason
why is I think it's very important to
draw a distinction between meta ethics
or meta more ality and I don't know why
people don't use the word meta more
allottee but what are the foundations of
morality that give us its foundation is
um for whatever verses morality and
ethics themselves like okay so what are
the morals that we pick I think that
biology and the constraints that get us
here and the goals that we have is both
individuals and social creatures clearly
are going to have a huge impact on how
we decide to actually be moral right
what counts as being moral etc but the
foundations of morality that doesn't
follow from those constraints or that
biology you can always choose to be very
different and no one can say that you're
wrong in the same way that the
could say you were wrong if you were
wrong about something scientific or
logical so I I would like to encourage
the world to just relax and accept the
fact that morality doesn't have an
absolute foundation and nevertheless we
have enough shared concerns and shared
desires that we can construct a way to
live that seems to us to be moral I
would disagree with that I mean I would
sign up for that you know I have to
understand more about how you were
framing the distinction between meta
morality and moral rules because if
anything initially when you were
expressing it that way I would have said
that the biology could provide a
foundation for the meta morality and and
and the sort of culture or history would
prefer fill in the specific rules so for
example not killing strangers might be
something that natural selection might
have shaped but a who counts as a
stranger might be something that's very
culturally specific or yeah so to me
both of those are morality so morality
is the killing strangers is bed met
immorality is why do we say that killing
strangers is that with a warrant what is
the justification for that scene and
rather than being a realist
whether it's contine or otherwise I just
want to be a moral constructivist and
says well look we we all think that
let's figure out how to live it okay so
so there are some arguments that are an
illusionary biologists have made like
Brett Weinstein and others that actually
the what was what has evolved is not the
content of moral rules but even the
capacity for world deliberation in fact
the argument is that what matters is
that we evolved to argue with each other
that serves a purpose it binds us
together the fact that we for example
don't fight don't kill each other
necessarily as a first instance we just
argued and that we might come to
different conclusions different
different groups of people
he quit endowed with the same capacity
for argument might argue a lot and then
at the end come to different conclusions
but the fact of arguing actually is
what's forming getting an outlet for
otherwise bad inclinations and also
binding us together by giving us
something to do so some people have even
argued that the very capacity for moral
delivery
is itself an evolved property that we
have so I you know I I understand I
think what you've said and I I don't I
don't think it's it's crazy but I still
think that I could you be more charm I
think you're probably right
no I mean a pluck you might already here
I think most people don't agree with me
including most professional philosophers
but it's just a matter of time right no
yeah you know the words that you're
using it's very similar to communicative
rationality right huh berm Ossian way of
thinking about how human beings interact
and how we come to things I think that
we have I even want in my less
charitable moments to say that this is a
relic of our religious upbringing the
fact that we want to find this absolute
bedrock logical geometric derivation of
things rather than just saying hey let's
come together and agree about it yes no
I would say that I would say there's no
doubt that modern moral philosophy owes
a lot to theology religion clearly goes
way back we don't know exactly how far
back it is we tens of thousands of years
but I also think that a lot of the stuff
we're discussing these sort of Moral
Sentiments like you to Pratap or
reciprocity for example the evolution of
the sense of reciprocity that you see in
elephants I mean that that precedes that
goes way back it's a pre religious
sensibility that we humans have or yeah
but they they have morality not meta
ethics they don't worry about a
foundational basis for their actions
okay it's uniquely human right view that
okay so when you write a book like this
why do you do it what who's your
audience what are you reaching for the
general public is this something that
you think of as part of your wider
mission as an intellectual or is this
just part of your yo scholarly Seabee
that's a good question I don't say that
there are many different reasons one is
its it's it's both painful and joyful to
write a book you know oh my goodness
yeah I mean it's uh it's it's a it's an
its it exercises a certain part
your minds a kind of discipline I love
the learning that goes into it you never
learn anything as well as what you have
to teach it and you know you really have
to drill down and drill down I love all
the meandering paths and you stumble on
stuff as you look at one papers
references then on other papers
references than other person that you
find this incredible classic some
forgotten scholar in 1890 who saw things
the right way who never nobody
understood it you know it's it's
incredible how smart those guys were and
you know we think we're discovering
everything so so all of that is very
joyful but it's painful you know it's
it's it's difficult to distill
everything down to to kill your darlings
to articulate it to finish the project
to allocate the time all of that stuff
so first it's just personal satisfaction
I like I like it this is my third book
my third unedited book I've also done
some edited some clinical textbooks on
write on hospice medicine so the first
one second point I think the audience is
my peers you're trying to make an
argument you're trying to say to your
colleagues you're trying to defend in
advance a certain perspective on the
world you're trying to say look I think
these ideas help us organize our
thinking and do you agree with me please
agree with me but this is a healthy way
to think about things and then I think
as you alluded to I think there's also
the broader public and here I think that
that is academics we have a even go so
far to say an obligation to serve the
needs know to advance the public
understanding of science I think you
know we the universities and academics
are are the institutions in our society
that are supposed to preserve produce
and disseminate knowledge you know we're
supposed to preserve Sanskrit and
preserve you know shell Anatomy and
preserve you know every obscure branch
of human knowledge and we're and we're
supposed to disseminate it we're
supposed to discover do stuff that's
clearly hugely important mission and
we're supposed to do that without
reference to its utility because leader
I think it's a mark of our civilization
that we we do this you know we we give
money to institutions that people that
just supposed to sit around and pick up
stuff
I mean I think it's miraculous I think
and I think it's the source of our
wealth that could make an argument it's
a source of our wealth and power and has
been you know ancient kings did the same
thing they know Galileo let's not forget
was in the pay of the meta cheese and
you know all of these sir you know uh
Archimedes worked it for the king of
Syracuse and so forth so we're supposed
to do that but we're also supposed to
disseminate the knowledge and we're not
supposed to just disseminating to
ourselves we're supposed to disseminate
it back to the our pay masters which are
the society at large and so I think in
that regard I think the engagement with
the public understanding of science and
the efforts to increase the the way in
which people see the utility of science
and of knowledge I think is important so
that's another reason to write books
yeah so I think very quickly very those
you do the same thing of course I I do
I was gonna say two things one just that
this this wonderful fact that you are
allowed just to dive into the literature
and the research and the other fields
and to be interdisciplinary and to talk
to people outside this is a wonderful
feature of writing books and I had it
when I was writing the big picture my
podcast audience here knows this but
this was a major motivation for me
starting mindscape podcast because when
I stopped writing that book my license
to knock on people's doors went away
right you know like how do I get to talk
to Nobel prize-winning biologist now and
but now I can do it cuz I have a podcast
so here we are so you might want to
start a podcast if you want to do this
and the other one I catch up with you
though Sean I think you're doing this
I'll just you and I it's a big ecosystem
out there and the other one is yeah I
think that it's very interesting to
think about the audience and how we
write books because especially in
physics there is a well-established
tradition of outreach popularization
books right where you're basically
trying to under do to explain something
that is perfectly well understood
general relativity or particle physics
or whatever and and sort of secretly it
shouldn't be secret I should be louder
about it but my books aren't mostly that
right my books are actually like you
said trying to make an argument
and you can disagree with them for the
most part it's not simply saying here's
stuff you know here's why he was moved
yeah I mean I'm trying to say like let's
go beyond a little bit and and partly I
do it in the trade book format to reach
a broader audience but but partly
because it is kind of a bigger picture
more interdisciplinary thing that would
be less appropriate for a professional
Journal article yes I mean I think
that's right and I also think there's a
way in which I mean this is a bit of a
craft of being a professor at our stage
of life I would say that I like to take
intellectual risks both in my own
laboratory I like to say my students
will say although the most hey this is
crazy but it's got to be true and oh
yeah and and and 50% of it more than 50%
I'm I'm right like they take bets on
whether I'm right or not and I have a
pretty good nose at this point for stuff
that's crazy but it's gotten true and
but it's very difficult to publish that
stuff in peer-reviewed journals as you
know and so until you get all the right
evidence I mean is that the path to
proving something is you know unusual
you know what is it extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence so but
with the books so that you can do is is
there not peer reviewed so one of the
things that I find very very welcome
about writing a book for four is that
you know why stand behind everything in
the book and I find deeply about it
research that at lengthen 20% of suffer
experiments I've done in my own personal
laboratory I know it down all the way to
the bottom level what's going on there
nonetheless you have more breathing room
right you don't have those peer
reviewers that are breathing over your
neck saying well you know what can you
say that I disagreed with that you keep
because I disagree our art 3 says
because I disagree with that cut out of
the paper you're like no no I want to
see this thing so yeah and it gets worse
the more interesting your work gets in
some sense ya know I feel myself like 10
or 20 years ago I was doing pretty darn
mainstream cosmology and gravitation
theory and I I never even contemplated
the possibility that a paper that I
wrote would get rejected you know it's
just that you you do the solid work and
it'll get accepted
these days I'm doing infinitely more
interesting work but it is more
speculative more interdisciplinary and
now I'm always worried that I'll get
read like half the time it sails through
vine and other half the referees decide
to be obstreperous but you know it's it
sadly and I really it hurts me to admit
this but my opinion of academia has gone
down in the last decade because as it
affects me personally the fact that
academia is so conservative and
traditionalist and hidebound is just
much more obvious and there's a reason
for that it's just like you know with
the evolution of different human
capacities right I mean there's their
sort of selection pressures that push it
in that way but it's too bad that
there's not more room in there for
encouraging just a little bit of off the
beaten path kind of stuff and the reason
why I say I'm looking to say it is
because there's it will give solace to
all sorts of complete crackpots who say
yes I miss it my my theory about how the
universe is made of pipe cleaners is
absolutely being rejected by the
establishment but so be it
well it's more than that first of all I
would agree 100% with everything you
just said in the last two minutes and
I've had a different career than yours
in different fields and and I don't know
if you've ever overlapped it in
universities but mostly different
universities and it's the same thing and
it's really you know sometimes described
my laboratory as the island of lost toys
like I've got I've gotten to the point
where I can provide some cover and
protection for my students and but I
worry you know because I you know I have
tenure and I have job security and I
haven't reached a certain stage where I
can take these risks but I don't know I
want to let them take their risks I want
to encourage them to it we all know the
famous scientists that swam against the
time made those major discoveries but
the truth of the matter is rugby one of
those we know they're 999 neither were
wrong or they were right but they spend
their whole life beating their head
against the wall and we're never
recognised in their lifetime you know
they were penniless and I know you know
no jobs and so forth even though they
were right so so we only hear about
those outliers who were right and
successful and it's very difficult to
organize a career or to mentor young
people in this regard
so I typically give the advice of you
know belt-and-suspenders I say you know
develop technical expertise develop
detailed knowledge about a narrow very
conventional kind of thing even and even
though you are young still have these
crazy ideas that you pursue in parallel
and just work harder you know do two
careers
until you get to the point where you can
really give yourself Liberty to go off
in crazy tangents I mean there's all
these guys at MIT these full professors
that you go talk to them you're like
well yeah this is the stuff I'm
publishing and sell but let me show you
the really cool stuff and their eyes
like you know I think you know we're
talking now about like different things
we're talking about just a crafted of
mentoring young people and we're also
talking about having a good life in
science and for me you know I would I
would rather I would rather take risks
that I might you know here let me just
tell you this and I'm sure you feel the
same way once you taste it at the well
of scientific discovery
there's no no other feeling like it
nothing like it nothing like it you if
you're the first to see something if you
give me the tiniest am thing and you
have that feel oh my god look at this
thing that I saw nobody has spotted
before seen it before yeah it's like a
drug right you just want it again you
know and you will invest years for that
again and uh and and so that's you know
I I try now that I'm at the stage where
I'm at and you know to allow myself that
pursuit and you know a lot of my grants
get rejected a lot of my papers get
rejected and I think more than yours
judging from your hit rate we're
striving but you know I would rather
that at this stage of my life that's the
game I would rather play well it seems
like you've been doing it very
successfully and at the very least we
have our books and podcasts to fall back
on yeah it's true you know a real
intellectual pleasure to be discussing
these ideas Sean thank you so much
alright Nicholas Christakis thanks so
much for being on podcast thank you
[Music]
[Music]